out of the mists of the Stone Age this
structure has stood since the dawn of
recorded history this rounded tomb
called Newgrange has stood in the bend
of Ireland's River Boyne for more than
five thousand years
it is massive distinct and very
mysterious the mound of Earth covers a
rock passageway which leads to a central
chamber where the ashes and bones of the
Dead were placed long thought to be just
a tomb in the late 1960s archaeologists
uncovered an amazing secret that shed
new light on this ancient structure on
the winter solstice the longest night
and shortest day of the year a shaft of
light enters a perfectly positioned
window and lights up the 60-foot
corridor that leads to the basin of
ancestral bones an impressive feat of
Engineering considering its Stone Age
builders possessed only rudimentary
technologies is particularly important
because it's been proven without doubt
that it was very deliberately aligned to
sunrise at the winter solstice its
facade is of white quartz restored by
archaeologists who believe the mound was
originally covered in a smooth stone
that reflected the light the massive
stones in the interior were perhaps
pulled from the river
the builders probably moved the boulders
into position by rolling them on logs
archaeologists believe it took decades
to construct Newgrange and since life
expectancy was short only about 40 years
the project likely was handed down from
generation to the next little is known
about the Neolithic farming community
that created this structure why they
built it is still a mystery
perhaps the mound was a place of worship
historians admit they just don't know we
know they were used as burial places but
we also think they would have been used
as places for ritual gatherings who are
pre at a focus for community gatherings
and placed an honor the ancestors for
more than 5,000 years Newgrange has
captured the Rising Sun of the winter
solstice it's a lasting monument to
human ingenuity and to a desire as old
as mankind even then people strove to
understand great forces of nature and to
harness them even if only for a brief
moment in time